Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us
I can't believe it, Moco-chan.
Start of a new week!
A brand new week together with the Ruffians.
Wow, Ruffians!
I'm sure you know.
You kinda know what FUWAMOCO Morning is right now, but there could be a few new ruffians joining us, so let us explain.
A FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Huh?
I... I faceplanted.
You did, you did.
I had so much to say.
You did.
And I really did a good job.
Wow, wow.
What was that, Moco-chan?
FUWAMOCO Morning is held on Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Well anyways, it's hosted by us!
Moco-chan, can you answer?
Who's us?
Are we?
I think so!
We are the FUWAMOCO!
And our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
We're off to a rather silly start, huh?
You know, some mornings you just sort of faceplant.
That's just how mornings go sometimes.
You took the faceplant for the Ruffians, right?
I did!
Now you're not gonna faceplant.
You can say thank you.
You're welcome.
Well, Ruffians!
I'm sure you all kind of know, right?
Well, we wanted to say thank you for using your eyes, keeping them open, looking around for Pero, because you know, sometimes, you know, it's extra good to do that.
Especially, you know, sometimes.
Because we've had another Pero Sighting!
Pero Sighting.
You know, because sometimes, if you're not careful, if you don't keep your eyes open, bad things might happen.
Just like this one Ruffian, I found Pero in there.
Dessert.
Pero.
Pero, what are you doing in there, Pero?
You shouldn't be in there, hon.
Maybe he's looking for pudding.
Pudding?
Well, I don't know if Pero's gonna find any pudding in there, but it does look really, really good!
Yeah, it looks good, right?
The mangoes, and blueberries, and mochi, and mochi, and those popping bubbles!
It looks really, really yummy.
Is that soft serve under there too?
It's ice cream!
I want some!
It's just the morning but I want dessert.
Morning is good all the time.
Sharing is nice so keep it up!
Were you able to eat this afterwards though, you know?
Pero, it can be pretty nasty, so I wouldn't be surprised if you made it kind of not taste that good.
You know, ice cream is pretty, it's a pure vanilla taste.
Pero, I don't think Pero tastes like vanilla.
Nasty, maybe garbage.
But if Pero made it taste bad, then I'll eat the rest.
It's okay.
Really?
That's nice of you, Moco-chan.
I'm always nice.
You take the sacrifice?
I will sacrifice.
I will eat the ice cream.
Well, hopefully, you know, it wasn't too bad.
If it was, maybe the next time you have dessert, things will go a bit worse.
Be careful when you're making it.
Make sure Pero's not in there, okay?
Food safety is important, right?
Exactly.
BAU BAU!
Anyways, please let us know if you have any more sightings, Ruffians.
Especially, please make sure not to eat them by accident.
When you're eating your food, make sure you do it in a well-lit area.
Exactly.
It's spooky otherwise.
Remember, please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next, some Ruffians might have noticed, but...
Lifetime Showtime!
Ruffians!
Thank you so much for 100,000 views on our original intro song, Lifetime Showtime!
Thank you!
We really appreciate you listening to it lots and lots.
It's, you know, it's special.
It's our own original intro song.
You know what I mean?
It's a lot.
We hope that we can continue to make lots of original music.
It's our special first, you know it!
But creating original music for A.I.C.E is, as a lot of Ruffians probably know, it's a big goal, a big dream of ours within hololive, you know it!
But you know, reality can be rough sometimes too, so we'll be counting on you to be passionate and
Share all your love for it, okay?
Okay, Ruffians!
I know it might be a bit difficult at this point, but I think we'd really like to see it maybe hit 300k someday.
300,000 views.
It might be a bit... We'd be very happy though.
Someday though.
Someday, right?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And I think there was also some big news today, right?
What's there?
De-den!
What is this?
Can you believe it, Ruffians?
When we woke up this morning, suddenly, now, we're senpai!
Right!
It was announced that a new group, ReGLOSS, will be debuting from a new branch within hololive production.
We also took a stab at what they might be kind of like on Twitter, you know, because we still don't know.
So we used the hashtag, hashtag Rigushira.
Headcanon thing that they're doing.
I mean, kinda guessed, you know.
We thought, you know, maybe that they're similar to Abbott, you know, like full of personality.
Yeah, personality, right?
What do you think, Ruffians?
Nobody, yeah.
Right, right!
Yeah, we're really excited, but we're also really nervous.
Yeah, we didn't think that we'd be senpai this soon.
To be honest, we still don't really know right from left.
Yeah, we're still learning words and making mistakes every day too.
Yeah!
Plus, you know it!
We still haven't been able to collaborate one-on-one with our senpai either.
One-on-one?
Two-on-one?
One-on-one!
Yeah, yeah.
You know, it's kind of a funny feeling to think that there are already others who are calling us senpai, but... FUWAMOCO-senpai, Mococo-senpai, Fuwawa-senpai... I don't know.
I don't know!
BAU BAU!
We'll be watching!
Well...
Ruffians, it happened again.
It might have just kind of happened again.
Just maybe.
Just kinda.
Kinda.
There's been another misunderstanding.
I was really hoping that we made it to two FUWAMOCO Mornings in a row, but... You know, our happy streak is broken.
Fuwawa.
She said something again that was misunderstood.
You know, during It Takes Two, we were working together and stuff, right?
And there was like a lot of different things that happened.
And I might have mentioned that the only reason that I live with Moco-chan is because, you know, of real reasons that it's out of obligation.
Because if I didn't live with Moco-chan, you know, I'd kind of be on the streets.
Moco-chan, you probably would be too, you know.
I could've just maybe implied that Moco-chan's only good for paying her portion of the rent.
Do you really think that's true?
It is true though.
But you know there are a lot of good things about living together with Moco-chan.
You like being with me.
Right, Ruffians?
Good things about living with Moco-chan.
You like being with me, right?
Spending time together.
Yeah.
Yeah, I like.
But you know, living together, it's nice.
It's nice too, you know?
Like being able to use Moco-chan's cards, you know?
Because Moco-chan, she gives me her cards because she doesn't want to hold them.
And so then I can use her cards when I feel like I don't want to pay for something.
And maybe I'll tell her afterwards.
Sharing is important.
Okay, Ruffians?
But you'll be happy too.
You'll be happy because then I'll share what I buy with you.
You know?
But sometimes, I don't want that.
Oh well.
Thank you, Moco-chan!
Thank you!
Is the misunderstanding cleared now?
Right.
Ruffians, they understand what I meant.
Okay.
Yeah, living with Moco-chan is fun.
There's lots of perks.
I like living with Moco-chan.
Do you, though?
Moco-chan, you like living with me too, right?
Because I cook and I clean and I make stuff and I fetch stuff for you.
I do that too, but yes.
Sometimes.
Ruffians!
I actually have something to confess.
It might be a little bit shocking, a little bit alarming, but... You know, during our Super Chat reading the other day, yesterday, there was actually something really weird that happened that we tried to hide from all the Ruffians.
We're really, really sorry, Ruffians, for hiding this from you!
We didn't want to alarm you, you know?
We didn't want to scare you, so we tried our best!
But...
Did you notice?
Something was happening to the entire stream.
There was something... SOMETHING in our room with us.
You know, we never gave it permission to join us, but the entire time it kept on distracting us and even surprising us!
Yeah, suddenly we'd just be like, uh, chit-chatting and then it would touch us and go close to our mouths and eyes.
It was... it was...
A small fly!
It looked exactly like that!
Just like that!
You know, with those big eyes and all the eyes.
If it was a cat, that would've been nice, but no.
We were really surprised.
You know, Fuwawa might have screamed a couple times, you know?
Yeah, I think I accidentally screamed twice.
Did you notice, ruffians?
It was not appreciated.
I don't know why though.
Why was there a fly in our room with us in the first place?
We're really lucky because we never ever have bugs.
It was that shocking, you know?
We never have bugs.
Maybe it was when we had the window open?
Not appreciated.
Were you worried, Ruffians?
Sorry, Ruffians.
Sorry for worrying you.
Stinky?
BAU BAU!
It was a tiny one.
That's why it was shocking.
Why?
Because it's not big enough to see, but it's tiny.
Tiny, you know?
Just suddenly I was like, what is... What?
Am I going crazy?
That's why we scream.
But it's gone now.
It's gone now.
Did you notice?
Did you?
Me?
Moco-chan, not you.
I didn't notice.
The ruffians.
FUWAMOCO is a bit silly, you know?
Screaming for no reason.
I guess we do scream for no reason sometimes.
Maybe they already think we're silly, huh?
Maybe.
You have no idea!
Okay, well, I'm glad we didn't alarm you then.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad he's gone.
Much better.
We actually also had something that we kind of wanted to share with you.
It's a bit of a new corner.
A new corner.
But we wanted to share something that we very much feel like
We like recently.
It's our new... We Dig It!
We Dig It corner.
Well, you know...
Everybody likes to relax at the end of the day, right?
And you know, after a busy day, we like to relax, but we also like to better ourselves too, you know?
So you know, naturally we think about how can we be better Demon Guard Dogs, you know?
What can we do to get stronger?
And you know, a strong BAU BAU is really really important.
So, we've actually...
We've been watching just regular dogs do their best BAU BAU!
Watch them bark and howl so that we can get strong just like them!
Maybe a bit more musical?
I think our favorite kind of dog, dog, BAU BAU is the Huskies.
You know, they're really popular with us right now.
Right, Mococo?
Mococo.
What?
I called you Mococo and it felt weird.
But you know, it'd be nice to be able to BAU BAU like a Husky, you know?
Ah, Moco-chan.
Wawa-chan.
What?
BAU BAU like a husky?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Good BAU BAUs.
Each dog has a different voice, so it's really fun to kind of hear how do they BAU BAU.
Right?
Accurate impression!
Thank you!
All the studying is paying off, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Next!
On the topic of music.
We have something that everyone's really looking forward to.
Our FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
BAU BAU!
Yes!
The day has come!
But I want to let Ruffians that maybe weren't here for the past week know for the past week, we've been asking Ruffians for a special jingle for FUWAMOCO Morning!
So we've been asking on Twitter for you to submit your own FUWAMOCO Morning jingles.
Give your best shot!
Your best... No!
Best... Best submission!
I mentioned it's only been about one week since we started asking for your jingles from you.
We were really surprised because you came up with so many great ones!
Thank you!
Super unique, super creative.
Really impressed.
We hope you enjoyed the process, you know, the creative process a lot.
And that hopefully, maybe you'll continue creating music from here on out too.
I'm really happy because I think there was a lot of Ruffians making their first attempt at music.
You know, their first jingles.
So we're really happy.
Ah, well you know.
I'll let you know something, but we will be selecting the jingle that will be used here on out FUWAMOCO Morning.
This is Friday!
But before that, we thought it'd be nice to be able to showcase a few jingles with you today.
Yeah!
Let's listen to some of them, okay?
Is that okay?
Are you ready, Ruffians?
You have to look like this, okay?
Get ready, put your headphones on.
Blast the music.
Listen closely.
Move the body.
You know it's morning, it's time to get going, right?
It's a jingle, right?
So you only have a few seconds before the dancing stops.
This first one we have a jingle from Jeremy Robson.
Moco-chan, can we take a listen?
Let's see if we have it.
I'll turn it off.
It's the perfect environment to listen now.
Okay, let's hear it!
This is from Jeremy Robinson!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's so nice!
Thank you!
Tell me about that.
This one has the theme of a morning news jingle on a local TV network from 1985 to 1990.
I like how specific.
It's very important.
But it definitely feels very strong.
Strong.
Yeah, yeah.
Grandiose.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like we are going to get the news to you.
We do it very, very well.
Give a smile to you.
We are going to make you smile no matter what.
What did you think Ruffians?
Very orchestral, right?
Lots of personality, right?
FUWAMOCO News!
Let's go!
I don't know.
I don't know if we have the skills for that.
Why?
Very important.
Thank you so much, Yumi, for the wonderful jingle!
Well, next, we have a jingle from...
Lily-chan!
Let's take a listen!
Lily-chan also worked on ano hi no bokura e for our hololive's Blue Journey, so we're really happy to see some ruffians and a fan of FUWAMOCO Morning too!
I wanna listen!
The guitar has this welcoming, very personable feel.
Reminds me of drinking a good cappuccino in the morning.
Very warm.
It's been good, you know, because the summer's over now and we're going to fall in winter.
It's getting a bit colder, so we need to warm up, you know?
Exactly!
Thank you, Dimension!
And for our next single, we have one from
Ka-na-bun.
Ka-na-bun!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a listen.
Okay.
FUWAMOCO
Ruffians, did you hear that last part?
Oh my gosh.
Beatboxing, right?
So cool.
You know, did you hear at the end there was the BAU BAU now?
FUWAMOCO Morning, BAU BAU now.
Moco-chan, do your best to beatbox like that.
Are you serious?
It sounds better than mine.
I guess you have to be taller than Moco-chan.
Ouch.
I like the BAU BAU now.
Right?
You know, I was thinking though.
For some reason, I feel like YouTube and beatboxing has a close connection.
A strong tie.
Right, you know, I feel like a jingle like this with the beatboxing might make the YouTube algorithm really like FUWAMOCO's channel.
Happy.
BAU BAU now!
Thank you, Kanna-bun!
BAU BAU!
And what do we have next?
For our last jingle to showcase today, this one's from WONDERWORLD!
Let's listen!
Okay, here we go!
Explosive!
That was... Wow.
Abyssgard, right?
It's a very violent start to FUWAMOCO Morning, you know?
Pero Morning!
One day we'll use...
I think you're better when you made this.
I think I should say you're thinking of me.
I love it though!
It's so great!
Moco-chan, don't you kind of want to make lyrics to sing along with it?
You know, like...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
We hope you enjoyed these few that we showcased with you today.
Yeah, we really, really appreciate all the thought and love and care.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Please look forward to the big reveal on Friday!
BAU BAU!
And next, we'll go to our regular corners.
Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
We have...
Oh!
Moana!
She's the Doggie of the Day.
She's not the fluffiest or the fuzziest, but apparently, you know, that's okay because she gives the warmest hugs.
But I was thinking, you know, I was gonna say, you know, she's not the fluffiest, she's not the fuzziest, but isn't she the most fashionable?
Whatever you want me.
I think we sort of look similar.
No, you're the fuzzy one.
Same fashion sense.
You're the fuzzy one.
She's the fashionable one.
Yeah.
Look at the pink dress and the smile.
The beautiful smile.
It's a very good smile.
But I think I like the cute tutu the best.
Right?
You know, the tutu is perfect because it lets her tail wag free.
I kinda have a feeling that it's doing a lot of wagging to it today.
She's obviously in love, right?
I can tell.
The look in the eyes.
Right?
Well, how does Moana BAU BAU?
I think she's very ladylike, you know?
Ladylike, you know?
Polite BAU BAU.
I like BAU BAU.
Not like the husky BAU BAU.
Not like that, no.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Very nice.
Ah, but you know, like you said, she may not be the fluffiest or the fuzziest.
Did I say that?
Ah, ah.
No, wolf mellows deru.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
But you know, I'm sure she's great in many, many other ways.
You know, like, like the smile there, right?
And the lovely gaze.
Yeah.
Not everything is about the fluff or the fuzz.
No, it's not.
It's not, you know?
That's okay.
But you know, you can tell that she really never, ever wants to leave your side.
She loves you.
BAU BAU!
And next we have... Today I went on a walk!
Corner.
Where did we go today?
It's so pretty!
It's a market.
It's sunrise!
From Asaichi, a morning market in Japan.
Looks like they have ramen.
Other yummies can only get there too.
It's a morning dream.
Ramen nice and early in the morning when it's still a little bit cold out.
You can enjoy it with the view!
Right!
We've never ever been to something like this before.
It's too bad there's nothing like this in the Northwest Pacific.
Ruffians, where'd you go?
First thing in the morning, wake up bright and early.
Asaichi.
And then after, FUWAMOCO Morning.
Oh, you go to Asaichi.
Maybe you have your ramen while watching the sunrise and then listening to FUWAMOCO Morning on your phone.
Right?
It sounds nice.
Oh, this morning mic is with you, too!
I'm not envious.
It would be fun, right?
And then you could go on a really wonderful morning walk, too!
Nobody's around.
Nice.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing!
Arigatone, BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day,
What kind of question do we have?
We have... I have a boat to pick with you two.
What's wrong?
I have a very serious job with very serious people.
We have an acronym that we use all the time.
BAU!
Business as usual.
No, BAU is BAU.
BAU is not business as usual.
How do I protect and hide my smile in these serious meetings when my colleagues start talking about BAU?
I think maybe the answer is a bit more simple.
Is it?
I don't know.
I think you know.
If your coworker, if they ask you, BAU, then you go BAU BAU.
BAU BAU, right.
Right.
Are they just being silly?
What are humans up to now?
The answer is always BAU BAU.
If your coworker asks you BAU, then you say BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Right.
It's good, right?
BAU BAU.
Yeah, just like that.
Just like that.
Exactly.
Maybe you should make sure to sign all the important documents with a paw print, too.
That way you know for sure that you mean business.
Huh?
Which one is it?
Business or BAU?
If you sign with a paw print, then you mean business.
Or you mean BA!
The same.
But Moco-chan, whenever we sign with our paw prints, you don't... I'm in business.
Very serious.
Ahoy.
You misunderstand.
It should be BAU.
Maybe you're the one who's misunderstanding, hoy.
Ahoy.
Did we answer the question at all?
Yes.
Okay, well, at least you know this Ruffian will now know
How to answer those poems properly though, right?
Exactly.
You ask BAU.
BAU BAU.
Yeah.
BAU BAU is always the answer.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians!
Listen, listen, listen, okay?
We want you to know we're always looking for more submissions for, you know, our Pero Sightings we had at the beginning, right?
And then we had a Doggie of the Day, and we had your walks, and then of course the question here.
Recently, there's been a little bit less submissions than usual.
Moco-chan, you were a little bit grumpy about it.
I didn't get grumpy.
I just thought maybe the Ruffians were forgetting, you know.
But you know, because of that, your chance!
It's now, Ruffians!
Please share with us a little bit of your world.
Don't hesitate!
We want to know it!
Use the hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
That's the hashtag!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
For our next stream, we're going to be playing the Adventures of Cookie and Cream.
Don't get confused, okay?
Because unfortunately we won't be having an evening stream tonight because we're going to be working on some homework.
So this is going to be tomorrow.
Tomorrow evening.
But yes, we're going to be firing up our PS2 for FromSoftware.
This time we're playing Adventure of Cookie and Cream.
You couldn't tell.
But it's a classic co-op game.
It's very colorful and a bit tricky.
I think Ruffians, if you enjoy it, it takes two.
You'll really enjoy this one too.
Teamwork, you know?
Please join us as we go on our adventure as two cute, funny FUWAMOCOs!
Thank you!
And our schedule!
We have a brand new schedule for a brand new week!
You know, not only are we just making our Minecraft debut with Advent, but we'll also be holding a very important Japanese Classroom with all of Advent 2!
We're gonna be becoming
The sensei for Advent.
But you know, we were sort of thinking that as Advent members, we might be able to collab with our JP-senpai, right?
Right, you know?
We wanted to make sure that Advent is ready to go and can communicate a lot.
You know that the Nihongo is okay.
Exactly.
It's daijoubu, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It's daijoubu.
So we're gonna do our best to become
The Sensei!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Sensei!
From Senpai to Sensei!
Wow, level up.
Alright.
You know, we're gonna do our best to teach as much as we can about the Japanese language, and try not to teach them maybe too many weird things too.
Let's do our best.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Mauve Eric!
BAU BAU!
Super Galaxy!
Charms!
BAU BAU!
Yang!
Tanuki-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Ed!
Yuki!
BAU BAU!
Yoshi!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!